[Music]
that is Sharon Stone when she shared the
honor of the sporting Muhammad Ali had a
charity event with Diana Ross and I
gotta say that Sharon of the champion
both had such a passion for giving back
and they you know they really did Nancy
they had a huge impact on so many
people's lives but you know share and
shared with me how Muhammad Ali changed
one life in particular her own I met him
when I was 17 yeah I was in the Miss
Pennsylvania pageant and he was in
Hershey Pennsylvania when I was there
and I met him and then he called my
father and offered me a part in his film
that he was making and my father said
she is not going to be in film and he
sold my father you may think that she is
not but she is you cannot hide that girl
under a bushel basket her light is too
bright one time I said to him you know I
met you when I was teenage girl and he
turned to me and he said yes and you
were wearing a blue dress the life
lesson Allie passed along to Sharon make
the world a better place well she was
doing just that as she helped raise
three hundred thirty thousand dollars in
County hosting the fifth annual hotbed
gala benefiting her charity planet Hope
I think life is a service job and
anybody who thinks they're self-employed
isn't Sharon and I talked everything
aging dating at 58 and sex with
strangers I read the article where you
were talking about finding a boyfriend
I don't want to take the time out to
just go on a date or have sex with a
stranger are you in a place where you're
like I'm cool if I don't have a
relationship I bought a dog which I
think was the best move ever because you
need a buddy so I don't want to just be
with someone to be with them but you're
still open to it yes I'm dating and when
it happens I'll be with it right now the
men in Sharon's life are her three sons
oh and there's this guy yeah leave it to
James Corden to create this rap video to
help Sharon score a quality date
would I come with a Nobel Prize she got
a genius brain and if bagon thousand he
came up with this and I said I'll do it
as long as I can have a grill and they
said okay and I was and I went to the
studio and I mean we did it in 45
minutes it was like boom boom boom boom
boom
one day I'm Sharon Stone